this story begins in 1985 when an age 22
I became the world chess champion after
bidding Anatoly Karpov early that year I
played water is called simultaneous
exhibition against 32 of the world's
best chess playing machines in Hamburg
Germany I one of the gifts and then it
was not considered much of a surprise
that I could beat certain few computers
at the same time to me that was the
golden age machines were weak and my
hair was strong just 12 years later I
was fighting for my life against just
one computer in a match called by the
cover of Newsweek the brains last tank
no pressure from mythology to science
fiction human versus machine has been
often portrayed as a matter of life and
death
John Henry called still driving man in
the 19th century african-american folk
legend was pitted in the race against
steam-powered hammer bashing a tunnel
from Allan rock
John Henry Legend is a part of a long
historical narrative pitting humanity
versus technology and this competitive
rhetoric is standard now we're in the
race against the machines in the fight
or even in the war jobs are being killed
off people are being replaced as it has
values from the earth it's enough to
think that the movies like The
Terminator or the matrix are nonfiction
there are
various instances of the Rena where the
human body and mind can compete on equal
terms with a computer or a robot
actually I will do a few more instead it
was my blessing and my curse to
literally become the proverbial man in
the man versus machine competition that
everybody is still talking about and the
most famous human machine competition
since John Henry I played two matches
against the IBM supercomputer the blue
now we remember that I won the first
match in in Philadelphia before losing
the rematch the following year in yield
but I guess affair there is no staying
history special calendar and with all
the people who fail to climb Mount
Everest before Sir Edmund Hillary and
Tenzing Norgay made it to the top and in
1997 I was still the world champion when
chess computers finally came of age I
was Mount Everest and the blue reached
the summit I should say of course not
that the blue did it but it's human
creators an answer man candle horns sue
hats off to them as always machines
giant was a human trial something we
tend to forget when humans are surpassed
by our own creations the blue was
victorious that was it intelligence no
no it wasn't at least not in the way
Alan Turing and other founders of
computer science had hoped
it turned a chest could be crunched by
brute force
once Hardware got fast enough and
algorithms got smart enough over by the
definition of the output Grandmaster
play level chess d-glucose intelligence
but even at the incredible speed 200
million positions per second D blues
method provided little of the dreams of
inside into the mysteries of human
intelligence soon machines will be taxi
drivers and doctors and professors but
will they be intelligent quoting quote I
would rather leave these definitions to
the philosophers and the dictionary what
does really matter is how we human feel
about living and working with this
machine when I first met D blue in 1996
in February I have been the world
champion for more than 10 years and I
played 182 world championship games and
hundreds of games against other top
players in other competitions I knew
what to expect from my opponents and
what to expect from myself I was used to
measure their moods and to gauge their
emotional state by watching their body
language and looking at the right and
then I sat across the chess board from D
blue I immediately sensed something new
something unsettling half you might
experience a similar feeling the first
time you ride on Rather's car or the
first time your new competitor manager
issues and all that work but when I sat
at that first game I couldn't be sure
what is distinct was capable of
technology can advance and leap an idea
had invested heavily I lost that game
and I could have wondering might it be
invincible was my lead beloved game of
just all world this were human doubts
human fears and the only thing I knew
for sure that my opponent be blue had no
such worries at all I fought back after
this devastating blow to win the first
match but the writing was on the wall
I eventually lost of the machine but I
didn't suffer the fate of John Henry who
won but died with his hammer in his hand
it turned that the wall of chairs still
wanted to have a human chess champion
and even today when a free chest app on
the latest mobile phone is stronger than
V blue people are still playing chess
even more than ever before juicers
predicted that nobody would touch the
game as to the Conqueror by the machine
and they were wrong proven wrong but do
saying has always been a popular pastime
when it comes to technology I learned
from my own experience is that we must
face our fears if you want to get the
most out of our technology and we must
conquer those fears if we want to get
the best out of our humanity while
reading my voice I would all of in
spirit all of inspiration
from my battles against the blue as
all-russian saying those you can't beat
them join them and I thought what if I
could play with a computer together the
computer at my side combining our
strengths human intuition plus machines
calculation human strategy machine
tactic human experience machines memory
could it be the perfect game ever played
my day came to life in 1998 and the name
of advanced chess when I play this human
part machine competition against another
elite player but in this first
experiment we both fail to combine human
and machine skills effectively advances
found this home on the internet and in
2005 a so called freestyle chess
tournament produced a revelation team of
grandmasters and top machines
participate but the winners or not
grandmasters not a super computer the
winners were a pair of amateur American
chess players operating three ordinary
pcs at the same time the skill of
coaching their machines effectively
contract counteracted the superior chest
knowledge of their Grandmaster opponents
and much greater computational power of
others and I read this formulation a
weak human player plus a machine plus a
better process is superior to a very
powerful machine alone that more
remarkably is superior to a strong human
player plus machine and an inferior
process this convinced me that we would
need better interfaces to help us coach
our machines
towards more useful intelligence human
plasma gene isn't the future its present
everybody has used online translation to
get a Jesus of a news article from a
foreign newspaper knowing it far from
perfect then we use our human experience
to make sense out of that and then
machine learns from our Corrections this
model is spreading in investing medical
diagnosis security analysis the machine
crunches data calculate probabilities
yet 80% of the way 90% making it easier
for analysis and this is making of the
human part but you are not going to send
your kids to school in self-driving car
with 90% accuracy even with 99% so we
need leap forward to add a few more
crucial decimal places 20 years after my
match with the blue second match this
sensational the brain's lost and
headline has become commonplace as
intelligent machines move in every
sector seemingly every day but unlike in
the past when machines replaced farm
animals nano labor now they're coming
after people whose call it degree and
political influence and as someone who
fought machines a lot I'm here to tell
you this is excellent excellent
eventually every profession will have to
feel this pressure or else it will mean
humanity has ceased to make progress we
don't
get to choose when and where
technological progress stops we cannot
slow down in fact we have to speed up
our technology excels at removing
difficult and uncertainties from our
life and so we must seek out ever more
difficult ever more uncertain challenges
machines have calculations we have
understanding machines have instructions
we have purpose machines have
objectivity we have passion we should
not worry about what our machines can do
today instead we should worry about this
what they still cannot do today because
we will need the help of the new
intelligent machines to turn our grant
these dreams into reality and if we fail
if we fail it's not because our machines
are too intelligent or not intelligent
enough if we fail it's because we grew
complacent and limited our ambitions our
humanity is not defined by any skill
like swinging a hammer or even playing
chess there's one thing all the human
can do
that's dreaming so let us read big thank
[Applause]